Bisher hat die Menscheit so etwas noch nicht
gesehen.
Das Bild eines Planeten, der gerade entstanden
ist.
370 Lichtjahre von der Erde entfernt.
Er kreist um den jungen Stern PDS 70, ein
mit 5,4 Millionen Jahren, relativer junger
Stern.
In seiner protoplanetaren Scheibe aus Gas
und Staub kreist der junge Planet und sammelt
immer mehr Materie ein.
Für Astrophysiker eine absolute Sensation.
Was sie bisher nur vermuten konnten, können
sie jetzt direkt beobachten.
Was sie gesehen haben und wie sich die Astronomie
jetzt verändert.
Das jetzt in diesem Video bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction.
Herzlich willkommen.
Noch vor wenigen Jahrzehnten 1992 wurden die
ersten Exoplaneten überhaupt entdeckt.
Der Pole Aleksander Wolszczan hatte sie im
Orbit des Pulsars PSR B1257+12 ausgemacht.
Bis dato wurde nur vermutet, dass es auch
woanders Planeten gab.
Doch sie waren einfach nicht zu finden, weil
sie kein Licht aussandten.
Die Sterne, um die sie kreisten überstrahlten
sie einfach.
Doch durch verschiedenen Methoden, wie regelmäßige
Veränderungen der Helligkeit der Sterne oder
ihrer Bewegung wurden in der Folge immer mehr
Exoplaneten gefunden.
Inzwischen sind es fast 4000.
Doch wie Planeten entstehen, dazu gab es lediglich
Theorien, die durch keinerlei Beobachtung
bestätigt waren.
Das hat sich mit diesem Foto geändert.
Es ist das absolut erste Bild eines neugeborenen
Planeten, der sich noch in seiner Geburtsphase
befindet.
Und es bestätigt genau die vorliegenden Theorien.
Auf dem Foto sieht man deutlich wie sich der
Planet durch die Scheibe aus Gas und Staub
um den Stern pflügt und durch das Aufsammeln
der Materie Lücken in diese Scheibe pflügt.
"Diese Scheiben um junge Sterne müssen die
Geburtsorte von Planeten sein, aber bisher
haben nur wenige Beobachtungen Hinweise auf
junge Planeten in ihnen gezeigt", das sagt
Miriam Keppler, sie hat das Forschungsteam
am Max-Planck-Institut für Astronomie kurz
MPIA in Heidelberg geleitet.
Diese Scheibe hat eine Ausdehnung von 130
Astronomischen Einheiten.
Diese Größe ist fast dreimal so groß wie
unser Sonnensystem, mit dem Kuipergürtel.
Der Planet ist 22 Astronomische Einheiten
von seinem Zentralgestirn entfernt, was 22
Mal weiter ist, als die Erde von der Sonne.
Dadurch, dass der Planet mit der Scheibe wechselwirkt,
durch Reibung, Bremswirkung der Materie und
der Veränderung der eigenen Masse verändert
er langsam die Entfernung zum Stern und räumt
so immer größere Bereiche in der Scheibe
frei.
Weitere Analysen zeigten ein imposantes Bild
des Planeten.
Er ist ein riesiger Gasplanet mit mehreren
Jupitermassen, die Temperatur beträgt 1200
Kelvin.
Wolken sind in seiner Atmosphäre und er bestätigt
mit seiner Größe, Temperatur und der Eigenschaft
eines Gasplaneten, dass sich solche Planeten
in größerer Entfernung um ihr Zentralgestirn
bilden.
Um dieses erste Bild eines entstehenden Planeten
überhaupt machen zu können bediente sich
das Forschungsteam ziemlich ausgeklügelter
Verfahren.
Das Instrument dafür war das SHERE am Very
Large Telescope der Europäischen Südsternwarte
in Chile.
Es ist das größte optische Teleskop der
Welt.
Dazu wird ein besonderer Effekt ausgenutzt.
Licht des Sterns, dass von seiner protoplanetaren
Scheibe aus Gas und Staub durch die Staubpartikel
gestreut wird, ist polarisiert.
Im Gegensatz zum Sternenlicht schwingt es
nur in einer Ebene.
Ich demonstriere das mal hier mit einem Blatt.
Licht kann so, so oder zum Beispiel so schwingen,
wird es
aber von der Staub-Gas-Scheibe gestreut hat
es danach nur noch eine Ausrichtung.
Mit diesem Wissen kann das Sternenlicht einfach
herausgefiltert werden und es bleibt ur das
viel schwächere reflektierte Licht.
Bam.
Plötzlich tauchen Dinge auf, die vorher nicht
zu sehen waren, wie zum Beispiel Planeten.
Zusätzlich wird der Stern noch mit einem
Koronografen, einer simplen schwarzen Abdeckung
ausgeblendet.
„Nach zehn Jahren der Entwicklung neuer,
leistungsstarker astronomischer Instrumente
wie SPHERE zeigt uns diese Entdeckung, dass
wir endlich in der Lage sind, Planeten direkt
bei ihrer Entstehung zu finden und zu studieren.
Ein lang gehegter Traum wird wahr“, so Prof.
Thomas Henning, Direktor am MPIA.
Es wird also mit dieser Technik noch zahlreiche
spektakuläre Entdeckungen in der nahen Zukunft
geben.
Wenn ihr keine Videos dazu und zu allen anderen
Themen verpassen wollt, dann added mich bei
WhatsApp.
Dann umgeht ihr die kaputte Abobox hier auf
YouTube und verpasst kein Video.
Denn über WhatsApp erfahrt ihr von mir noch
vor allen anderen vom neuesten Video - täglich
garantiert.
Einfach hier draufklicken.
Und am besten auch meinen Schwesterkanal Clixoom
Social & Media abonnieren.
Da gibt es das neueste aus der Social Media-Welt.
Dafür hier klicken, aber nicht die Glocke
vergessen.
Hier geht es weiter mit (dafür drauf auch
klicken) „Antares: Spektakuläre Aufnahme
enthüllt überraschende Entdeckung!“ Bis
dann, bleibt dran!